presenta como un techno que pongan con
amplia experiencia
casi prácticamente
aludiendo temas y ahora lo vimos en el
discurso con temas de anticorrupción
como como parte de ese proceso siguiese
el gasto y hemos tenido en la en la
sociedad costarricense se le achacan
obviamente no se mencionaba al puro
principio todo lo toda la situación que
se presenta por su por su sanción en
temas de acoso en el en el banco en el
marco mundial y por ente se hace un
ligue directo con él con el tema de
derechos humanos sin embargo me parece
que más allá y hoy vimos algunas
pinceladas y lo hemos estado bien en
algunas pinceladas de acciones concretas
en el accionar del gobierno por ejemplo
obtuvimos por primera vez en
20 años de traspaso representación de
los pueblos originarios tuvimos la
presencia de la primera cacique
costarricense que representa a una de
las etnias esos esos elementos uno
podría verdad esté un poco escuchando al
señor presidente en poder pensar que el
tema de derechos humanos lo puedan lo
podamos ver tal vez en una forma más
amplia